welcome everybody to another YouTube
hangout really excited to be here with a
new friend of mine mr. Peter Hollens has
a super successful YouTube channel 1.5
million plus subscribers he is a singer
extraordinaire Gunz does tons of
acapellas has his own songs there's a
lot of mashups and collaborations if you
haven't checked out his channel I highly
recommend you check it out I would start
with the Amazing Grace version that he
did that's some epic listen that you
should get into but he's also managed to
make a name for himself in a career off
of YouTube making more than a full-time
income building up a team he's on
patreon makes 5 figures every time he
puts out a new song he joined the board
of patreon he's expanded that to go work
with major companies like Disney and do
collaborations people Jason Mraz lots of
fun stuff has just launched a new
creator Academy that is coming up to
help creators make a full time income
plus from their art mr. Peter Hollens
welcome aboard man hey thanks so much
Evan got to be here so I got to tell you
you just launched a song from The Lion
King the circle of life yeah my wife and
I wake up to that song every day it's
our it's our get out of bed song I have
my my phone set for 7:00 a.m. every day
and we hear the rasa Gwen yeah yeah yeah
yeah the original yeah well yours came
out like six days ago or something right
yeah yeah that was a great version
though like how hard was it to learn the
words for it um man Swahili is not an
easy one it is not an easy one uh the
the language is definitely one that is
easy to reproduce if you like break it
down phonetically I did a full Swahili
song by the name of Baba yetu uh and
that that was incredibly difficult but
this is just like the beginning part and
then it goes into English and everybody
thinks they know how it sounds but
putting in the click it looks like the
correct like click you're that that
that's the hardest part but alright I'll
have to talk to Nina my wife maybe we'll
switch our morning routine to wake up
the Peter instead so instead of Disney
we'll see um cool thank you for joining
us today I'm wondering just just quickly
share your story how you got started
and you know how you got just from
putting up videos on YouTube to where
you right now some of my lessons learned
for the audience is already a ton of
questions is up coming in but just a
little more background than on your path
yeah sure um you know what my mother
forced me into choir in high school I
thought singing was for girls so go mom
they're always right I ended up going to
college on a full-ride of music
education in voice performance because I
wanted to be a choral director because
my co-director kind of changed my life I
ended up figuring out very quickly that
classical School of Music's kind of like
drain your soul and passion for music
like you know God love them but they're
only like forcing down Mozart and Bach
and you're I'm like yeah but no one
cares about that and studying three
months for an opera that you do two
performances for it's not too rewarding
so I started an acapella group at the
college after my freshman year we got to
do pop music the 18 year old version of
Peter Hollens like desperately needed
affirmation from my peers and so it was
really nice to start doing pop music
that people appreciated and so I fell in
love with the human voice I started
eventually taking all my money that I
had saved for my master's degree and I
basically bought myself a home
recruiting recording studio I started
recording acapella groups all over the
nation I did it up for about seven years
along the way fell in love with my wife
she auditioned for a cruise ship so I
basically had to go sing on cruise ships
if I wanted to stay married to her I
mean stay you know that make it happen
and so I turned into a cruise ship
singer half the time and then we kept on
recording all cappella groups you know
Yale Georgia I mean just about anywhere
um and then the the sing-off called uh
called me the producers that sing op
that was an NBC show that was very
similar to American Idol but for
acapella groups and they asked me to put
a couple groups together for them
because I knew a lot of acapella people
I ended up helping my wife put a group
together for the show and then my
collegiate a cappella group was in
recording a an album at the time and I
convinced them to do it because I didn't
want to do it and one thing led to
another and I can't I went down and
auditioned
with them and I ended up having like
three or four solos on national
television um
and that actually 2010 like November
December of 2010 did nothing for my
social brand or input like because it
was in the name of my acapella group it
was on the name of Peter Hollens I had
never started any social media site so I
like during the show when it was airing
I opened up my first social media
account like Twitter only because I saw
on Twitter that they were talking mad
smack about me and I like wanted to
respond I was like oh yeah yeah I love
my hair looks really cool no uh so after
being in that experience being
surrounded by a bunch of singers who
wanted to make a living singing I was
like yeah I want to do that and so I
kind of turned the mic on myself and you
know my tens of thousands of hours of
the studio really paid off because I was
like well I know how to do acapella
music I could just sing all the parts
and so I started recording my own
content it was very obvious to me back
then that YouTube was the best
distribution platform for music and so
just like I taught myself music
production i started teaching myself
video production even to the point and
this is like the one thing that
everybody gets caught up on whether
you're you're any type of crater like i
was it was completely bare bones like my
my music my video production was
literally started no no focused focus on
like an object where i was going to move
the object and then stand in front of it
start the camera go in front of it do my
thing go back be like crap that's out of
focus do it again like you know and then
i just taught myself the platforms and
started releasing content and being the
most shameless self-promoter as possible
and started reverse engineering what
other people were doing and one thing
led to another and i'm addicted to
working now and doing what I left for a
living I loved it I did the same thing I
had my sister record for me focused a
camera but then leave the room because I
couldn't do a video with her the room
yeah yeah yeah I couldn't figure out how
to focus it myself and put like a
mannequin or something in the room so so
I had her but I think
we all go through those phases I
continued on the journey at what point
did it turn from okay this is
interesting you know I'm having some fun
doing this to actually breaking through
when either getting an opportunity or
certainly make money from it or no
patron wasn't even around I think in
those days what led to that breakthrough
for you
so yeah Patriot arted four years ago
that was like 2013 but so 2011 I was
doing it part-time obviously any
business you start you start losing
money all my videos are getting maybe
somewhere between you know 15 and 45
thousand views that like tops which is
just isn't enough distribution to like
make it work although I had extremely
low overhead it was literally just my
blood sweat and tears so all of the
quote-unquote profit was just like I put
in time equity and I made some money
back visa vie ads and then selling and
distributing um my music online so I
think I maybe had ten or twelve pieces
of content on my channel um when Lindsey
Stirling reached out to me and she said
um you know Lindsey Stirling she's like
an absolutely incredible musician she
makes electronic like comes in right
yeah yeah she's when she's won like best
um electronic album like billboard
musician of the Year last year's but yes
she reached out and said you know I saw
I saw one of your videos you look like
you're a lot of fun we should do
something and I went online and I
checked around I was like this person's
like tenfold or more like what I like
why'd she want to work with me but then
I but in my head I was like blown away I
was like how do I work with a violinist
I'm like that doesn't work with my brand
anyway I got over that quickly uh and we
work together and she she taught me in
one in one collaboration in like one and
a half days that like you treat your
fellow creator as a peer and not a not
as competition and that it was all about
we kind of like the raising tide lifts
all boats like that it's about the
ecosystem and helping one another um
just kind of completely shifted my mind
not only did that specific video I think
it's at like 70 million views or
something on our two channels but it
paid for my rent that was like the one
song it just kept on consistently paying
for my rent just that one song I'm like
okay so I need to collaborate with
people non-stop but but more
specifically just shifted my mindset
from what we were subconsciously taught
growing up that like you know the first
thing that's trying to do what you're
doing is your competitor and if they
succeed you're not going to succeed I
mean that's kind of what the music
industry like throws into your head you
know with all these award shows and like
album charts and like because all that
stuff doesn't matter like music isn't
about competition it's about well it's
about music which is like the language
of love and the more of whoever your
favorite artist is working with another
one of your favorite artists you're
going to be stoked it's not like you
only have one artist on your iPhone
right right um so anyway so she kind of
was my I entered that entire wave of
thinking with that collaboration and
moving forward I'd collaborated non-stop
when I tried to provide as much value to
every single person that came in contact
with just like she was did she did that
for me so it's nice when you get
basically single-handedly half of your
mind like shifted by just one person
that I owe her so much she knows that I
basically tell her that every single
time I see her and everybody you talk to
you - it's great yeah I love it so so
for the youtubers watching our artists
feel they have a skill set whether it's
singing or playing an instrument or
being a thought leader and they want to
use YouTube to expose their message turn
it into a full-time career and plus and
build a team and have a bigger impact
but they're struggling you know that the
early days what kind of advice you have
for them people that are just starting
out yeah I think I think considering
that this is you know May of 2017 now I
think it's quintessential to make sure
that you are doing something that you
love and that you can
that you can do you know 80 90 hours a
week and that you're positioning
yourself to start thinking about I know
this is not like a popular thought
process but because of the over
saturation in the marketplace just
entirely online in on every platform I
really view it as quantity over quality
which is completely not what most people
talk about but you need to bombard an
audience with your brand and your
content non-stop and that's almost a
necessity not only for like the YouTube
algorithm that is basically a non-stop
treadmill that's only speeding up more
and more so you need to be able to feed
that monster but truthfully like the
metric that you want to be paying
attention to is just getting yourself
your brand your face in front of an
audience as often and is yeah I mean as
often as possible and in doing so you're
able to then provide value to them
non-stop and and hopefully you know I
mean I hate talking just like business
because it sounds like I don't because I
carry such a great deal about my family
members my Hollins family which is like
my my core audience than anything but
like you need to be able to get your
face in front of them so that you can
then push them and monetize them and
convert them in places that were you can
actually keep doing what you do as for a
living so find someone that you look up
to the II respect that is doing
something similar to you and literally
copy what they do I know that everybody
know when it says like oh my gosh don't
copy I'm like if it if it isn't broken
don't fix it like if something is
working for somebody it's working
because they've they've they've done it
they failed
they've started succeeding they've like
figured out what's working what's not
working so at least start there and then
start adjusting it and making it your
own I mean that's literally what I did
my who's my Mike Tompkins is like one of
my really good friends now but in the
beginning I was like this is working for
this guy he's creating music in a
similar style to me I'm gonna release
content identical to him
and then and then I was like okay this
work this work this work and that all of
this didn't work and then I slowly
started adjusting it making it my own
and I feel like no matter whatever
whatever kind of content you're creating
that's quite essential just like its it
would be so intelligent for you to find
ten like-minded or similar craters to
you and start making dark Facebook posts
like five dollars a day to each of their
audience to say like if you like
so-and-so I think you would like me or I
think you would like use yourself in a
talk of a third person but you need to
grow your brand on YouTube you need to
grow your ban on Facebook you need to
grow your around an Instagram I see
those as the three pillars of content
right now um I mean I don't know I'm
very a DDL to start talking in circles
until you like point me wondering also
everyone I'm so sorry that I look like
this
I'm shooting a Anastacia video after
this so I had to shave and part my hair
in the middle like a total freak oh but
this is not how I usually look I usually
like much more groomed and handsome like
the man right here with it look at how
license beard is just the same size and
everything this is this is as long it's
a lot to go before the wife starts
freaking out so I hear you I do I load
up soon I'm a big believer in in the
content I like to tell my audience the
quantity lead to the quality like the
more you make the better you're going to
get it doing it you got to put in your
hours what kind of quantity are you
suggesting so if I'm getting started I
want to get my my brand out there I want
to produce on YouTube how often should I
be doing it in your eyes yeah I guess
there's two ways of thinking I hate like
saying the actual truth truth to people
who haven't started yet because it just
paralyzes them and 99% of the time
people just need a freaking start yeah
with that said that if you truly want to
be successful building a digital brand
online you have to be releasing
significant pillars of content at least
weekly and that even comes from somebody
who had to stop doing weekly because he
had a kiddo and I'm building back up to
it now but I have a digital brand I have
to record 200 tracks and it's impossible
for me I lose my voice and I can barely
keep up with it but
the right answer is at least weekly uh
if not bi-weekly or every day I'm sorry
that I said that I don't don't hate on I
think I honestly I think Daly's a new
minimum you know maybe it depends on
what you're doing on what your specific
niche is and how how smart you are at
building your audience and then how far
down like the fan acquisition funnel
they are and how much of an evangelist
they are so that you may truly only need
a thousand real patrons or evangelists
to be able to be totally successful but
Daly's pretty quintessential I think I
think you can also look at as you have
strong pillars of content that take much
more time to create and then maybe the
other content you're creating is
documenting that journey or doing behind
the scenes but you you need to put your
face in front of your audience as often
as possible yeah and and the Daly is
really one for you to get better at
whatever skill talent you're trying to
improve but also like that point it's
the YouTube algorithm like they want
daily you can win without going daily
but you're riding on the slow streets
instead of going on the highway you like
right it has to be good right it's got
to be you don't want for whose daily
crap but again the quantity will lead to
the quality it's really I mean we do
three times a day on my channel and you
did a you know hundred million views
almost there 700,000 subs we just
crossed today um grads
yeah yeah I won't do a live party but we
cross it like 1:00 in the morning or sub
like PMSing a belly um
juice anyway and I think so for somebody
who is struggling I think I think the
truth is helpful to know that this is
what you need to get to even if you're
not there now like you don't need to
produce daily content because as you get
better right you want to do it faster
right like your first video probably
took you a week to do and now you can
sit there in the studio and bang that
out way faster right or something very
similar with it but little more time but
yes yeah I think musicians are at a
total disadvantage for the current um
algorithm even though that's not the
best
term to use for the learning processes
and like AI that they've like basically
created this algorithm for that you know
is much more considerate of watch time
session watch time audience retention
than anything having to do with a view
right the view metric has been destroyed
ever since Facebook came out with their
um video marketing scheme that was
brilliant um so yeah I mean the one
thing I would like to point out that
that hasn't been talked about is like
you know II even though I've built my
hub and I am so aligned and and
interested in always being on YouTube
because I feel like they care about the
creators the most but it's not it's not
about what platform you build your
following on in fact as we go further
into the fact that we're kind of all
turning into robots because of
Technology there's going to be more and
more platforms coming out all the time
that will basically get to like a
hundred million users quicker and
quicker and quicker and if you're an
early adopter of the next snapchat or
the next musically and you're anywhere
near like the top one percent you're
able to take that audience that you put
there provide a value proposition to
other craters on other platforms that
you want to cross pollinate and cross
promote and they want to become
something on that platform and vice
versa it's I think this marketplace is
all about being a creator being an
entrepreneur and being an incredible
early adopter and it behooves you to be
reading all the time paying attention to
the industry leaders and whatever
vertical you care the most about and and
baby basically I think it honestly it's
it's not rocket science it's like if the
ten people that you care about most that
are doing similar things to you if one
person starts doing something new that
you've never heard of you might as well
take a half an out of your time and and
try it too because there's a reason why
that person just just just started on
Marco Polo or whatever it
and follow what they're doing and how
are they utilizing it and see if and
mimic it having it you don't have to be
the first but you have to you have to
move very quickly it's interesting I
take an almost opposite approach where I
want a platform to really prove itself
and then I know I can come in and just
out execute but not everybody has the
ability to do so yeah and um I feel like
I would say that your approach in my
approach can live harmoniously because I
you can still out execute and be an
early adopter and then double win
because okay yeah so you can you can you
get then you could say but I only have
so much time to put in the day towards X
Y Z and and sure but there's certain
processes that you could put into
account where it's like I can streamline
Twitter this way I can streamline
Instagram this way I mean I could get so
much so too granular maybe I should back
up but there's multiple approaches right
yeah I like it
I think people that are just starting
have to be early adopters because
there's too much saturated saturation in
the marketplace for there to be a
hundred
Evan Carmichael's right I mean I just
don't think that necessarily will work
just on YouTube but your entire brand
and idea and an ethos in a different
setting on a new platform could work
terrifically but competing with you on
your own platform is very difficult
right right unless you find your own
unique angle right like you're not gonna
everybody nice to have that you can't
you can't out Peter Hollens Peter
Hollens no matter how hard you try
you'll just be a cheap imitation right
but you could be the best Jimmy Stewart
or like whoever you want to be next so
although I asked you this and if I'm
just getting started I'm a musician
coming up I'm just starting today am I
even on YouTube where am I going and my
falling your strategy on say you're on
everything so if you release it so if
you record one song and you're like this
is my thing I did my research I know
that this song is going to be successful
because it's the SEO is growing and the
Google trend show that it's growing
Spotify
uh accounts are accounts are picking up
it's it's getting more radio play I know
that this is going to this is going to
hit at the right time and you release it
you do it first you do all your tags
right you do it in a way that's
incredibly personable so that you're not
a product but you're a person and
secondary to the fact that you're you're
like charismatic and you're passionate
and you're inspiring you also sing and
you're also good versus the other way
around you can't be a musician first in
a person second you have to be a person
first and a musician second I'm sorry
this is 2017 there's a reason why people
like the Kardashians just annihilate the
world not only because the mothers of
genius but because personality reigns
that's just where we are right now so
you need to be performing directly to
camera I need to be looking directly
into you need to looking directly into
the soul of your viewer on every single
um like you know here's the here's a
fourteen-year-old kid that's just going
through YouTube and they find you if
you're in some like high production
slick music video I don't care how good
your song is I don't care how good your
voices or how attractive you are
this person isn't going to connect with
you as a human being and we're living in
a digital world where there's very
little human contact and the best way to
now connect with an audience is to be
singing directly into your audit like
directly into the into the lens so
release your content simultaneously on
Facebook and on YouTube and create a
multiple versions for instagrams those
would be my three platforms that cost
right on specifically um but if I'm just
getting started do i following your
early adopter strategy am i really like
over index on understanding musically
and whatever is coming up next and say
like I need to dominate this because my
talent is still rising it here's working
crush oh how old are you you mean you
kind of have to like break it down right
musically is like for the ten to fifteen
year old so we're I mean if you're if
you're like a grizzled old man you're
not gonna you're not gonna
you're not going to do that well and
musically you're gonna come across you
know you're not going to be authentic
for that platform
um right okay but let's say okay let's
say that Lion King song just dropped
right like it's just going about this
week and here's Peter Hollens doing a
version and here's all these other guys
who've been doing it for years have
their version they have the crew they
have their team they have their system
down they're going to make super
polished YouTube videos Here I am I want
to make my version of it I'm just
sitting on my iPhone doing it it's not
going to be as good so I won't get as
much leverage as you guys will I'll get
something but you may not be on some
other platform and this is where I can
over-index potential if I understand it
where even though I'm not as good
because I'm earlier I can get that
leverage what we're essentially talking
about so is there is there if I'm just
getting started is there another
platform that you write
yes I'm going to post to Facebook
Instagram YouTube but then I'd be
somewhere else with my content because
it's going to be hard for me to compete
on the big platforms right now until I
get better I mean literally if that's
your example that I would say there's no
reason why you are really seeing a cover
or a version you know once a day or
twice a day because if it's just you and
your bathroom with an iPhone mm-hmm you
know then then there's multiple places I
would tell you to go like you should be
able to build a fanbase singing live
unlike you now you should be
lip-synching to the same content that
you're releasing on other platforms and
pushing people there you should be
utilizing hashtags on Instagram to
search the exact artists that you just
released and you should be DMing
influencers and trying to provide value
to them and to get them to be to check
out what you just did I mean it's like
when I started I mean gosh there was
this website called Empire Avenue okay
yeah Empire Empire was like cloud 2.0
but like gamified and really weird but
it allowed me to become like a top dog
on there and have people who you know
Mia's very much internet marketing but
those people had 100 X 150 X the
following that I did and I was able to
provide value to them in a
to get them to share my stuff and that
you know maybe early on that gave me an
extra 25% a better distribution it's
like my point is you have to constantly
be looking and seeing what other people
are using where is as other people's
eyeballs like we're dealing with an
attention currency that is that is hard
to quantify by like specific metrics of
like you should release on Facebook you
should release on YouTube like yeah you
should be everywhere if I'm starting now
I'm following exactly in the footsteps
of the people I look up to most I'm
utilizing their playbook the thing that
they have to their advantage now is they
have a road that has been like basically
created for them I mean the early
innovators what they what they had to
their advantage was that less saturation
they were the first to do something but
they would run into multiple multiple
failures now you can go back and you can
see how did voice Avenue get to where
they were how to cure Hugo Schneider
goods at or they were added pentatonix
actually break into the mainstream how
did like and you can watch from the
first video yeah what did they do and
like just learn um so do your point like
it would depend like I would need to do
one-on-one consultation with who that
person is what's their instrument what
makes them unique what makes an audience
actually attracted to that person is are
they super like personal centric like
should they be opening up the beginning
of their video with like jokes because
like Josh Groban people don't know
unless they've seen in live with that
guys I think more funny than he's even
like I mean he's a terrific singer but
he's like he should be a stand-up
comedian so like if I was Josh Groban I
would like lead into my context okay
I'll just go it does whatever he wants
cuz Josh Groban these days hey you can
always get better good but but but my
point is you know what are your what are
your biggest strengths and you should
utilize that because in the end it's
only about creating engaging value to
your cut to your audience if if if
singing is one element of it great but
if you're if you're if you're great at
juggling this is ridiculous
if you're great at juggling and you can
sing I mean like
in the beginning if you need a stick you
need a stick you need to build an
audience if that stick is the algorithm
of doing covers then great do it make it
your own eventually but but initially
copy what you think what you like and
that you think works and if you're and
if you're doing something over and over
and over and over and over getting not
getting any traction then you need it
you needing change and experiment and
depends on the platform so I wouldn't
need you so much more specific to like
join the creator Academy well we're
going to talk about that but but just
quickly my own my own quiet my own
thinking of your channel so I mean all
your stuff is such amazing high-quality
well produced multiple angles to your to
your part about storytelling and
Kardashians and you'll be a human first
what was the conscious decision to lean
away from mixing in you know Peter at
the dinning dining room table just doing
a live sing-along or some song just
comes out you're in the car on your
phone like blast in a way like why not
do more low low quality personal stuff
and only go the high quality Mary yeah
well I mean I created a digital brand
that's impossible to to recreate live
right
I can't clone myself that's not a
possible thing so I created a means
where my brand was only able to be
reproduced in high production I mean
when I was stupid enough to sign a major
record deal and I had an agent banging
down my door to sign a contract to do
you know a 25 citywide national tour and
a manager and my wife telling me to do
it my my family time you'd do it I was
like there's just no way that I could I
can create any type of real value live
that I can online it would be stupid for
me to do so and I would rather take all
my time and energy and creating content
that people can take in and perpetuity
online because the future is digital the
future is an analog in person but I
digress if I was a different musician I
would be experimenting much more so and
I'm going to start creating content
that's much more documentary education
behind the scenes blase
that's like lifting the veil because I
want people to be able to learn from
watching me not only for me teaching
them but literally like watching my
process so that I can have more more
content so to your point I need to take
my own advice
I think I did pitch in hold myself into
a place where it's almost impossible for
me to provide real value to my audience
at scale given the brand that I've
created so it's kind of like and maybe
it's easier for me to say because it's
easier to for me to point be like I know
this will work better why aren't you
doing it then to be pointed out myself
but I am I am changing my entire
strategy this year um because I do want
people to know and learn and understand
me better and and know the people that
make my work amazing cuz it's not just
about me yeah
one you know what brands can evolve you
just have to decide you say this is a
new direction people will follow you
along the new direction and you'll lose
some people is like Peter I don't want
to hear your vlogs man like that's not
why I signed up and other people like
dude thank you so much for sharing your
journey this is awesome I'm so glad you
did it um like Gary Vee was only doing
his askgaryvee show that's what was and
then he added his vlogs and you know
that like dude ah I am NOT a like a like
a fanboy of anybody but I am in love
with that guy well I just hope I just
love him so much I think he's just so
real and he's so unapologetically him
and he actually does and he says it
because I think Gary says everything but
like he provides so much value to people
if you just listen and like see what
he's doing and see how he's acting but
then even like just listen to like he's
trying to force-feed you to basically
get you to act and get off your butt and
stop making excuses I'm like yeah that's
like that's human nature now I'm like
this guy is legit so it's so fun for me
to watch him and be like what I'm doing
Israel is the right thing it's like
there's I'm in Eugene Oregon I have no
one to talk to so like I listen him and
like I like pep talk
thanks Kerry I'm gonna go guys work well
but look at how his YouTube brain is
evolved baby his channel was only his
public speaking speeches write him on
stage for an hour then it then he's
launching askgaryvee show and that
picked up traction and he started the
flaw
and I think that more traction and he
lost some people some people like you
know I don't like the vlog like I just
want the practical tips but he gained
more people because people like
following along the journey as well so
you can evolve your brand at anytime if
if you want to go in that direction
share I know we're running short on time
I want to respect what you're up to but
I want to also quickly touch on creator
Academy new program you launched I know
it's sold out right now first round
we're going to link in the description
afterwards people want to join quick
like what is it about why did you start
what can people learn yeah absolutely um
you know what I like waking up in the
morning and making my daily life not
about me and not about just making music
and every single time I collaborate with
people I I force fade them with a I
consult them whether they like it or not
I I love educating people I want to do
it at scale I want to help people do
what they love for living I think the
only way to make this world a better
place is so that allow people to
basically do what they're meant to be
doing like if you know in your heart
that you should be doing X but you've
never tried it I want to help give you
the tools to in which to do that and I
can't take somebody from 0 to 100 but I
know I can take hundreds of thousands of
people from 0 to 60 and I want to do it
in a way that isn't about me like
building a company making lots of money
but me actually providing value to the
students and so building lots of courses
specifically proof of concept initially
will be music I'll teach you how your
teacher your instrument you to music
production teach you video production
and then teach you macro ideas like
community management branding licensing
distribution legalities um just if
anyone wants to be a creator um and then
yeah we're going to go from there
with lots of other partners and but it's
so about now when's round that's
entirely it's not necessarily sold out
actually to be honest I just stopped I
stopped I stopped advertising because I
had too many people signed up I was like
oh crap I don't want to make all these
people wait I'm still building the
curriculum but it's been it's just my
website Peter Hollens calm board /
creator Academy um honestly the people
who who sign up early I'm going to be
basically giving giving stuff away in
the beginning because I want people to
just like digest it so I can
easily create multiple iterations but
like you know like I'm gonna build it in
a way where if you if you buy course X
and that course gets changed to like 50
different versions you're gonna own that
in perpetuity
you know in perpetuity so you can get
every iteration of that forever so it's
not about like it's a subscription and
you owe me $150 a month in and every
month I'm like no we have aa Full Sail
Berklee School of Music all these like
internet marketers are taking advantage
of the people who are the poorest the
people who have the most desire to do
what they love for living the people who
I think can actually change the world
and I want to create something that
allows them to succeed at least at a
part-time living and teach them what
companies that do like to trust like the
infrastructure the greater revolution
that's occurring right now is one of
which I want to be part of and so that's
what I'm gonna do I love it man I love
the passion looking forward to see how
this all unfolds for you last question
one of my fans the Duke favorite wants
to know Peter what is your favorite
Disney song to sing ah no no um god gosh
I I just love Disney so much honestly
anything that Alan Menken wrote is just
gold well I don't know Alan Lincoln Alan
Menken's like um Aladdin Lion King
Beauty the Beast like all like the
iconic literature you know um I did a
disney medley uh back in 2014 with my
friend Alex gee I really like that
because it's like you get you get like a
min and a half of like a bunch of
different iconic songs I guess that's
really fun to sing I think I might do
that at VidCon this year cool but um
yeah okay I apologize for this face and
this hair is not usually the way I look
like it's not good Peter I know you got
a run thank you so much for spending
some time with us today the great
answers you gave the wisdom you shared
and best of luck with the the songs
coming up and creator cutters Mel I
really appreciate it man
thanks I appreciate it